2,5 tư tháng người, tổ chức i tế thế giới về kép hát où cho biết,
năng phải vật lộn với việc cách sảm mạnh gần sách cho các trường hợp hình gấp nhìn đạo trong năm nay,
và trình vòng cho năm 2019 không trăm 2020 có khăn.
Về kép hát où cho biết, năm nay đã nhận được tài trở ít hơn 1,5% sổ vấn năm 2019.
Chào các trường hợp kíu trợ hình gấp trình vàn thế giới.
Zodó, câu qua này đã rất khó khăn khi phải lợi trọn trường hợp nào được yêu tiền trong số hơn
và trăm chủ người cần hủ trời nhìn đạo.
Tình nếu tháng 9 2019, hơn năm 2019,
tế liên quan đến hỏng động nhìn đạo đã phải cách giảm dịch vụ trong khi hơn 2019,
phải tận nương hỏng động, lắm dầm khả năng tiếp cận dịch vụ ít tế của năm 2018.
Về kép hát où cạnh báo, chình vòng năm 2019, tự thử dưới rất ám đạm.
Đặc biệt ở những quốc gia như cộng hòa dân chủ công gồn, suốt áng và hay ti,
nơi tình hình ngày càng số đi, tiền lại suy zình dưỡi trẻ và tiền lại ở ba mẹ ra tăng.
Chính các tập chỉ như qua, các chuyện ra cho biết việc các giảm ngân sách sẽ dẫn đến hồng chiều
cà từ vòng đáng lại có thể tránh được.
Trong khi đó, tổng giấm đông với các hát o tư tốt át danh ngủy pressure,
cho biết điều đáng lòng ngày hình cả, là sự suốt giảm đáng kể trong việc hủy trở cho hàng chục quốc gia thủy nhất thấp.
Ông cho biết, ông nhận thấy một số điểm tích tự trồng cách các quốc gia đáng thiệu
của người tình hình. Nhưng của gia đáng tức tình và thay đổi từ suy theo hưởng vì động
một lực trong nước trời thống y tế mà ông các các trình hợp hình gấp.
Mí vốn là nhà tài trở lươn nhất của VHHO đã tuyên bố sẽ giúp hỏi tổ chứng này và các giảm mạnh biển trở nước ngoài.
Sống khi đó, các nhà tài trở quốc tế lưng khác cũng đang phải thích lưng bộ mộng.